So I remember this scene.
I remember this
being one of our first scenes together.
- Yeah.
This was our first day together.
And it was really,
you know, one that would set the tone
of the entire relationship.
But to be honest my memory is about
how much Lily affected this entire scene.
We need to be quiet for a while.
I remember now
looking at the Redcorn family's
antique Spode dishes,
which they finally got back that
year at I'n-Lon-Schka they were feeding
people off of rented plates
but these have been
the plates this family has used
for the last 100 years to feed people.
I remember asking when I had a list
of what would Molly be serving
Ernest and chose the grape dumplings.
I was just about
to say the grape dumplings.
Don't you want a bite of this?
They got too much sugar.
I decided that I'm going to serve him
what has the most sugar in it
as a diabetic
because, you know, it's
just kind of knowing that
that's probably what he was there for.
Can never be too sweet
now can you?
It makes me sickly.
By identifying him as somebody that
you know is after something
but she's also sitting in the same room
with him,
flirting with him, courting him,
getting to know him.
And it's really the culmination
of what to me has been
one of the most bizarre and twisted
love stories I've ever been a part of.
And also this,
the element of... that you were talking about
with the with the storm as well,
that was your input.
The storm. It's...
well it's... powerful.
So we need to be quiet for a while.
When the storm would blow through like that
it's powerful.
So you need to sit
kind of in reverence of it.
You need to sit and receive
what it's bringing.
To remain quiet through all of that.
And my... my character's sort of...
Still reaching for the whiskey.
- Still reaching for the drinks.
- Still wanting a drink.
Still wanting to relate,
still wanting to have a small talk.
Yeah.
And I remember that being, you know,
you're the one who came up with this idea
for the line about it.
It's good for the crops, that's for sure.
Well it'll be good for the crops.
So it's, you know, kind of doing that
Blackbird Talk thing, filling
the silence and me just creating it
and allowing it to sit.
And I remember talking to Marty, too,
about just sitting, because oftentimes
when you do these scenes, you're like,
“What do I do next?”
- Exactly! How do I fill the space?
- He had to
articulate quite a few times to us, “No, no, no.”
“Just sit and watch the storm.”
It's good for the crops, that's for sure.
Just be still.